[Music]
the Rich Roll podcast
hey everybody welcome to another
monologue episode of the podcast my
third and what appears to now be an
ongoing Series in response to your
enthusiasm for the previous two
okay
let's set the scene it's 1998
and I find myself coming too I'm
nauseous wildly hungover confused trying
to ascertain the nature of My Strange
whereabouts scrambling to fill in memory
gaps my skin clammy stuck to plastic
sheets and a bed that I don't quite
recognize my surroundings are entirely
unfamiliar but
none of this is abnormal like most
alcoholics I had grown accustomed to
waking up in strange places wallowing in
that very specific dark and private
shame and then in this moment it hits me
this dawning realization that the
countless bad decisions the errant
Behavior the disconnection from self and
my absolute inability and at times
downright refusal to change
despite so many attempts to stop
simply could not figure out how to stop
drinking a condition of both body and
spirit that had really left me broken
alienated from my friends it left my
family fractured I was in this state in
which I was unemployable
really incapable of being honest
utterly hopeless entirely alone
desperate in this condition of not
understanding how to live and wanting to
die and all of it all of those emotions
all of those decisions and behaviors and
actions
had all conspired I was realizing in
this moment to deliver me to this
foreign place we casually call Rehab but
let's be honest it's more aptly
described as a mental institution and
despite
degrees from Stanford and Cornell Law
School and this idea that I harbored
that I was some kind of intelligent
person the truth was pretty inescapable
my best decisions had now led me to a
certain form of insanity
I ended up spending a hundred days from
Spring to Fall in that institution which
was a treatment center nestled in the
bucolic Hills of Rural Oregon
and it was an experience that quite
frankly saved my life and taught me this
really powerful new set of tools for
living
it gave me hope it lifted me out of this
permanent midnight to coin of phrase
from the great writer Jerry Stahl and
provided me with a foundation upon which
I could rebuild this very broken life of
mine and it ended up birthing an
entirely new one the very beginnings of
the extraordinary life I enjoy today
started on that first day and here I am
this husband who's been with my partner
for 23 years I'm a father I'm a
stepfather
athlete author podcaster and an
entrepreneur who now shoulders
responsibility for the lives of the
people I employ how did this happen
more importantly reflecting back on that
it was an experience that set in motion
this journey that I've been on towards
greater self-actualization that made all
of the things I just mentioned possible
to begin with a journey that of course I
continue to pursue to this day with
extreme imperfection I might add and I
bring the story up
simply to illustrate that change is
possible I don't consider myself gifted
or particularly special in 1998 I can
tell you that I was convinced that I
could not change not that change would
be hard but that change was impossible
for me
and yet
here I am
but my story is not unique I've seen it
repeated a thousand times over and
because of what I do for a living I'm on
the receiving end of countless emails
letters and messages from people all
over the world regular people sharing
openly and with courageous vulnerability
their stories of personal change
amazing tales of transformation
far more extraordinary than my own
all of which leads me to one conclusion
no matter how lost
how confused how alone or how desperate
you may be or feel
there is always hope
there is always help if you seek it
what I'm saying is change is possible
transformation is within your grasp
always
and for so many reasons I've come to
believe that
it's your Birthright to grow we were
born to evolve it's something that's
imprinted on our DNA it is our mandate
but there is a caveat and it's a
powerful one at that
and it's captured in this saying that's
often repeated within 12-step
communities and it goes like this
change isn't for those who need it
it's for those who want it
translation
it's all about willingness
now one of the first questions I was
asked when I found myself in this
treatment center after sufficiently
drying out was and this was asked to me
by a counselor rich
do you want to change now
most people provided they are even
slightly sane would respond of course of
course I do look at my life it's a
disaster help me change please
but only a mentally deranged addict like
myself would need to take a pause before
answering to consider the options hmm
on the one side
we got a lonely painful Craven life
enslaved to substances
that's inevitably going to lead to
incarceration harming myself harming
others and probably death or on the
other hand here's this life that you can
have joyous happy and free
huh I don't know man
I gotta think about that
luckily I ended up opting for door
number two but many don't
those people die earlier than they
should I've been to a lot of funerals
but for some reason I was blessed with
that willingness a willingness born out
of a desire to survive I suppose but
also pain this pain that was so severe
it eclipsed the very real fear that I
held about change any kind of change
about letting go about surrendering
about asking for help and being open to
actually receiving help
I think that pain saved me but the point
I want to make is that you don't have to
be in pain to change you don't have to
hit rock bottom in order to make
alterations to your life pain makes it
easier of course but the truth is that
change is always within your grasp if
you can summon the willingness to ask
for it and again and most importantly
receive it when given
so back to the story me and that
counselor Rich do you want to change
yes
I do
great
he says
then you only have to change one thing
what's that I say
he says
everything
yes
and all I could think in that moment was
everything
what does that even mean
after the break I'll explain
we're brought to you today by Roka
glasses are not something you normally
think about as a piece of performance
gear which when you think about it is
kind of insane because you can't perform
at your best if you can't see well the
Geniuses at Roka basically rebuilt
eyewear from the ground up no matter how
active you are or how much you sweat
these things never slip or fall off your
face they're super durable they look
awesome and they've got tons of super
classy modern styles to choose from I've
been rocking rokas for about four years
at this point I love them I'm a big fan
of the Hamilton style and gloss black
that's this Frame right here as well as
clear or I guess they call them vintage
on the website and if you want to try
them out for yourself you can do that
right now and unlock 20 off your order
with the code richroll
roca.com or you can click the link in
the description below okay back to the
show
[Music]
welcome back
okay so how do you change one thing when
that one thing
is everything
well after 25 years of attempting to
answer this very overwhelming and sort
of Zen cohen-like proposition I have
learned a few things I've got a few
thoughts
which are challenged to articulate
without coming across as super
reductionist but with the understanding
that this may sound pithy I'm going to
try and I'm going to begin with the idea
that
you have to do it one breath at a time
you have to do it one thing at a time
one hour at a time one day at a time and
you have to bring to that experience a
certain presence
an intentionality a focus placed
squarely on just trying to make a better
choice every time a decision is
presented to you
beginning with the smallest most mundane
low risk decisions that greet you every
day
and then building from there
most days are one step forward one step
back some are no steps forward two steps
back but every once in a while you get
one step forward and no steps back
a brick laid on the foundation
and tomorrow
another opportunity
this process often means taking
something called contrary action what
does that mean contrary action well it
means asking yourself
what have I historically done what do I
typically do or want to do or feel
impulse to do in this type of dynamic or
situation
and then
what is the typical outcome of that
historic Behavior
now if you're living thinking and
behaving out of Integrity in other words
out of alignment with your values with
what we can call for purposes of this
talk your higher aspirational self
with what you know deep down to be right
and correct for you
then I suspect that outcome is generally
not great
an outcome that moves you away from the
result you seek away from the person you
aspire to be an outcome that also often
produces drama conflict angst and
sometimes even downright chaos
now ask yourself what would insert
person of Integrity you admire do in
this situation or perhaps better yet
what would the best version of yourself
the grounded calm mindful
sane person the person you wish yourself
to be the person you would be proud to
be do in this situation
contrary action means doing that instead
that is the essence of contrary action
now the rub
the funny thing about contrary action is
that it will generally feel like the
exact wrong thing to do hence the word
contrary
because your typical reactive
sub-optimal response is a neural pathway
that has been deeply fortified and
reinforced from a lifetime of reflexive
repetition by definition the contrary
action will instinctively strike you as
completely wrong contravening every
impulse sometimes every fiber in your
being about how you should behave in
that moment but this moment is your
moment of truth
a moment maybe even a millisecond in
which you either do what you've always
done
or you summon the adequate presence of
mind the awareness to actually do
something different no matter how
uncomfortable or counter-intuitive it
may feel and sometimes precisely because
of how uncomfortable or
counter-intuitive it does feel
until it doesn't
until slowly
bit by bit
invisible to your senses perhaps even to
others
this new neural pathway begins to take
root
and from that over time
the emergence of a new habit
until one day
that new habit is wrote
a healthier more aspirational
new default response to a certain
dynamic or externality that may in the
micro
seem absolutely inconsequential
yet in the macro when repeated over the
course of years or decades with
extreme consistency in patients these
contrary actions build upon each other
they create a momentum a compound
interest guaranteed and FDIC insured to
alter the trajectory of your life in
positive ways you cannot possibly
imagine or predict this process also
means again and no way around it
asking for help
despite any overwhelming belief in your
ability to manage and solve these issues
on your own or your resistance to
bothering others with your baggage you
need to invite others in you need to
bring them in so they can help identify
your reflexive recurring thought and
behavior Loops that are invisible to you
and help you construct healthier
responses
this requires being open requires being
honest and vulnerable with a few people
that you trust by Outsourcing your
decisions to them before making them
and then and and this is the part that
really gets often overlooked in the
conversation about mentorship or therapy
not only do you need to hear and
consider the consensus feedback but you
actually have to take the action
recommended you can't just hear it and
then do what you want
even when
especially when you may disagree
until the contrary action itself becomes
reflexive and then of course no longer
contrary but instead integral
a very helpful tool when grappling with
and learning how to practice this notion
of contrary action is to develop the
habit of pausing when agitated to avoid
reacting to situations the way you
always have
and instead indulging a moment to First
reflect
in other words maybe don't immediately
respond to the upsetting email until
tomorrow walk away from the computer you
know that's what you're supposed to do
sleep on it talk it through with that
trusted friend it also means another
Trope how you do anything is how you do
everything
how you make coffee how you interact
with the grocery clerk how you take
feedback from your boss how you respond
when someone cuts you off in traffic or
what you choose to notice or pay
attention to while walking down the
street
it means
slowing down
calming down
and this is why consistent meditation
and mindfulness practices are essential
non-negotiables
now whatever modality you decide to
engage with through this process whether
it's therapy or 12-step mentorship or
even just friendship
that's less important than the honesty
with yourself and others that you bring
to it I cannot over emphasize this
enough because that Honesty
is the portal to the clarity required to
track a new trajectory because you can't
set a course forward without first
establishing an accurate map of the
landscape
second to this and because who you are
is how you behave and show up in the
world
each step forward every contrary action
these things build a new identity
narrative that is being crafted in each
moment in real time a healthier identity
that becomes slowly more and more
aligned with your previously dormant
self-actualized potential an identity
that with patients and also with toil
let's be clear
will inevitably lead to things you may
not currently believe possible like
forgiveness of self and others
and making peace with your past so that
past as painful as it may currently feel
to confront
no longer haunts you no longer holds
power over how you show up in the
present and most importantly no longer
dictates your future
of course there's much more I could say
about the mechanics of change far too
much for the purposes and confines of a
brief monologue so let me steer away
from the three-dimensional for the time
being and bring this to a conclusion
with a bit of Homespun spiritual
mysticism
to underscore a point made earlier
I believe that I am here
you are here we are here to evolve
to grow as both individuals but also as
a collective and I'm convinced of this
transformation is our Birthright
but again
expansion isn't something we do in
isolation growth is a team sport it's a
muddy road that we journey together at
High Noon In The Heat Of Summer because
skins we desire to shed the pains we
Harbor and the patterns that keep us
stuck those things thrive in the dark
caves of isolation but they perish in
the bright sunlight of community so when
we summon the courage to illuminate or
place a spotlight on our flaws and our
fears and our pain in the company of
others
we suddenly realize
we're no longer alone that
although the facts of our respective
Lives May differ wildly
there's great unity and commonality and
shared Humanity in how we experience
life
and within that comfort
and perhaps most of all
hope
now maybe you're bristling at the
suggestion at the wounds of all of this
but
let's get honest with ourselves
deep down repressed compartmentalized
and perhaps shrouded in a protective
coating of fear crafted out of this
false sense of self-preservation or an
illusory sense that your pain is unique
to you and you alone
I think we all know this to be true
beyond the ego beyond the pull of the
material world nests this beating this
pulsing signal
nudging you in the direction of growth
it's like a yearning a feeling you've
always had deep in your soul this
knowing this
strand of code embedded into your core
processor that's tugging you towards
greater self-actualization gnawing at
you for deeper alignment between your
thoughts and your actions
it's not something that's rooted in
logic
it's not rooted in rationality and I'm
not sure science can account for what
you simply know to be true
which is that you seek to be better
and you know you can be better you may
not understand it
may not yet have shape or clarity
but this is a reminder
that this feeling that you have is real
and it's powerful it's like this
Meridian that defines us as human beings
that unites us as a collective that
represents the future self in gestation
and it's something that's freely
available to all who seek it anytime all
the time
all I'm saying is honor and respect this
truth appreciate its realness
and if you're listening to this and you
find yourself adrift
in search of a purpose
make this that purpose
and take that first step that first
contrary action
and I'll tell you what I'll meet you
along that muddy Road
and when you ask me
so just how long is this road
I'll say to you
don't worry about it man
just
take the next step
[Music]
foreign